good morning good afternoon good evening
to whoever it is in the world that you
may be third time this week that you
have to view this ugly mug but we have a
reason for it I promise NBA tread
deadline has come and gone compared to
last year a little lackluster for being
completely honest around here but how
were we ever going to live up to Kevin
Durant being traded at 1: a eastern time
that was not going to be the case
tonight I think the biggest name out
there in our uh in our predictions of
players that could actually be uh traded
today or this week when we did a
previous show was de jonte Murray and he
ultimately was not moved so
understandable uh I'm going to let the
chat load up here for a second as we go
live this is going to be a 30 minute
stream where I've got some topics I
don't want to call it a recap because
some of you here in the bleacher report
app have been doing that for a majority
of the day but I'm going to be reacting
now that we've reached the finish line
to the events that have occurred and the
results of which and how I think the
rest of the season will play out most
importantly this is meant to be an
interactive stream this is Q&A all right
just because I have the topics doesn't
mean that you're supposed to sit there
on your hands so if you feel like I'm
out of pocket or if you have a question
comment or concern I hope you find this
to be a safe space in uh sharing your
thoughts is I will be reading the chat
and the producers of bleach report will
be assisting Me by putting some of the
chats here in the Stream as well so with
all of that said let's get to it because
we have a limited amount of time we've
got some games tonight as well and while
I could have used that as a segue to
lead off with the Lakers because they
have the Kobe statue being revealed
they're wearing the mama jerseys tonight
we'll get to them in just a second but
how do you not start off any trade
deadline reaction show without
discussing what the New York Knicks have
put themselves in a position to be
currently as well as in the near future
for decades all right these gray hairs
did not grow themselves on my head I am
a Knicks fan that is well into his 30s
I've got a gray hair for every Knicks
game that occurred between the years
2001 and 20020 and a lot of the reason
for that is because when the Knicks
continue after all those years to go all
in on guys that were not named LeBron
James Kevin Durant you name it and they
go after whether it's Amari stmy Carmelo
Anthony Stefan Marberry they clear all
their cap space and assets uh to go
after LeBron James in free agency and
ultimately strike out they always seem
to put their chips in the middle when
they're drawing to minus estimated value
but let's fast forward to current day
where the New York Knicks today have
traded for Buon bogdanovich as well as
once a Nick always a Nick Alec Burks he
was there for the 20121 series against
the Atlanta Hawks was arguably one of
the next best players in that entire
playoff run but today the Knicks are
able to acquire OG and anobi as well as
Buon bogdanovich and they didn't have to
give up any of those future assets that
they have those future assets that the
Knicks are holding right now when they
moved off that 11th pick to open up the
c space for Jaylen Brunson they acquired
a whole bunch of first rounders that
have some heavy protections to them in
addition to the picks that they already
have we're talking about eight available
first rounders here that the Knicks can
can move in any potential deal and with
Buon bogdanovich now on the roster in
New York people he is not only a fine
player that can do anything that you
need right now he's the best player was
the best player on the Detroit Pistons
when Kate Cunningham's not on the floor
they're running their offense through
him he's posting up he's taking the
shots down the stretch but if you need
him to be catching shooting someone
coming off the bench he has proven
throughout his long history as an NBA
player that he can do that as well above
all this is not just a rental for the
New York Knicks he has a non- guaranteed
contract going into next season what is
likely going to happen pending injury
and or suspension or or some
catastrophic event is the Knicks are
going to pick up the fully guaranteed
part of this deal they will then have 20
or roughly $20 million in buan
bogdanovich money on the books for next
year and when you have put yourselves in
a position now that I think we can
unanimously say that the Knicks are not
title contenders as of this very moment
they're close they're on the doorstep
but that's the key word here yeah R boy
I hear you everyone in the chat saying
the Knicks are winning at all we can get
there and as someone that I've created a
Nick ceiling as like a second round exit
while they had RJ Barrett on the roster
they continue to make these moves now to
finally put themselves in a position the
correct way not just selling out on an
Amari stmy who doesn't even have
insurance on his knee in that contract
the the Knicks have put themselves in a
position now with a team that is going
to be a playoff Contender as well as
next year when there's that inevitable
NBA disgruntled Superstar it happens
once every other year for as long as I
can remember when that next disgruntled
star comes about and says trade me to
New York and New York only the receiving
team or the team that is holding said
disgruntled Superstar is going to be a
lot more to having the conversation
about trading said guy when buan
bogdanovich is the salary cap filler and
it's not Evan fornier because
bogdanovich is ready to go no matter
what the circumstance is right now he's
gonna help the Knicks as of this moment
as is Alec Burks but it puts the Knicks
in a position next year that if they
need to match salaries for someone
making 450 million you can include
bogdanovich you can include God knows
how many first round picks whether the
Knicks own them or it's one of those
protected picks from moving down in the
draft this is as good of a position as
the New York Knicks franchise has been
in since the mid90s it's someone that
has followed every dribble of every game
I can't tell you the last time the
future has been this bright and there is
a light at the end of the Lincoln Tunnel
it has been this big for so long but now
the world is there in a star the stars
align that you can match up someone with
jayen Brunson that is worthy of him in
being a co-star how do you not feel
what's the worst case scenario here the
Knicks have the team that they've
currently constructed it's going to be a
Conference Finals contending team as is
they are right there people and for the
first time in a long time it is time to
believe in bing bong number two sorry
that was a lot of talking I will go to
the chat Trey says as a Knicks fan we
can make the Eastern Conference Finals
still kind of scared of the Celtics as
the Knicks are currently constructed
right now they are not beating the
Celtics in a seven game series I can be
a Knicks fan and confidently say that if
this was March Madness Any Given Sunday
single elimination I'm open to the
conversation but that's just going to
require the Knicks to win four out of
seven games in which they don't have
homecourt advantage against a team that
is simply Superior to them now if
Mitchell Robinson were to come back
maybe we and and look like he did before
the injury we can have a different
conversation but as currently
constructed this Nicks team will fight
its hard out getting to the Conference
Finals Eugene kravit says if the Knicks
get and stay healthy they can compete
with the Celtics they can Force six-game
Series final score I believe of that
Celtics Nicks series as the teams are
currently constructed would be Celtics 4
Knicks 2 nicks lost the trade Jason 06
would you care to elaborate uh Quinton
Grimes God bless you uh as someone that
has spent the week coming into this
stream talking about Quinton Grimes love
him to death his great attitude he's
exactly what you want in a 2024 NBA
basketball player he is Catch and shoot
he plays three in D he's got great work
ethic he's got a great attitude ude and
he's going to be freed in Detroit he had
fallen out of favor with Tom Tibido for
whatever the reason he lost his starting
spot the Nick have made moves but divon
chenzo Josh Hart even ogan and Obi are
starting to siphon away all those
minutes Duce McBride ends up getting the
contract instead of Quinton Grimes the
good news for Detroit is that you will
have control of Quinton Grimes for
roughly the next half decade so God
speed Quinton and I hope that he gets
the run that he so deserves in my
opinion there in Detroit let's move on
to take and prediction number two it's
got to be the Warriors and Lakers
standing Pat I know Warriors fans are
sitting there saying we're just about to
waste another season of Steph
Curry probably the truth but with the
emergence of Jonathan kaminga the past
two weeks who is absolutely Killing In
The Name of D'Angelo Russell in La the
moment his name gets included in the
rumor mill he just erupts they have both
proven to be Mainstays in a on a team
that has playoff experience as well as
proven themselves as individuals that
they can handle it so it's like just do
it in the playoffs they they've both
done it in the playoffs guys and I I
understand the Lakers and Warriors fan
bases feel as though I don't want to say
they are entitled because I don't want
to get roasted but I'm thinking it I'm
thinking of a synonym for entitled you
feel like that you're the Warriors
you're in the you're at the end of your
Dynasty but it's not over yet and when
you're the Lakers you assume every
player wants to come here why can't we
just snap our fingers and get to jonte
Murray and the answer for that is
because you already did that with
Russell Westbrook you spent all of your
assets getting that man into uniform you
were lucky to get in return for him what
you did but the Hawks did not trade to
De jonte Murray to anyone today because
they are in the same position with
Deonte that the Lakers were in with
Russell Westbrook that the Warriors have
found themselves in with Klay Thompson
those are different circumstances and
they were both Acquired and or resigned
in different ways but my point here is
when these teams like the Hawks overpay
for Deonte they have to sell to their
fan base if they're going to move off of
Deonte after this short sample size of
him playing alongside Trey young that we
were able to get equal return for what
we paid and at the end of the day they
did not get the same amount on the
market that satis that fulfilled their
lust for a deal we heard about the Utah
Jazz we've heard about the Lakers the
Jon is going to remain with the Atlanta
Hawks so now you've got this Golden
State team that's in 11th place yeah
they get Draymond back they're looking a
little bit better kaminga is taking the
leap up they're finding some some run
with these young guys but is anyone in
this chat confident that the Warriors
are undoubtedly gonna come out of the
Western Conference this year the answer
to that is no and they're most likely
going to have to qualify through the
playin tournament so they're going to
have to play one or two games there even
before the one and two seed have to show
up they're going to get a week's worth
of rest against those guys so we're
going to go to the off season if we're
the Warriors and then they will
re-evaluate this whole Klay Thompson
situation and do you really trade the
guy I mean it is the Splash Brothers man
I know Steph Curry is the all-time great
but I just don't see a world in which
you are ever trading Klay Thompson
unless they are completely rebuilding
it's the one guy who gets like that that
Mafia esque pass right when you get your
button like Clay's got his Warriors
button man and I know he's a bad deal
he's not even closing he's not even
closing games right now but they stood
pad for a reason and all of those assets
that they can use on a trade they didn't
spend them for a
reason so no de jonte and also no Bruce
Brown I thought the Lakers if they
weren't going to get to jonte would be
in the market for Royce O'Neal or Bruce
brown but it's going to the Lakers have
no move besides D'Angelo Russell there's
no one on their roster that they can
move besides Max Christie that is an
asset they have no trade they have no
trade pieces left you have to match
money in the NBA and when you're so deep
into these luxury taxes it also
restricts who you can sign and or trade
for there are new rules with the
collective bargaining agreement now and
the Lakers are stuck to either a
D'Angelo Russell and Max Christie trade
or nothing and that is why you saw what
you did today we will go to the summer
with LeBron James and his 50 plus
million doll player option and go from
there number three on the takes and
predictions is that the mads are
continuing to dig and I didn't specify
digging a hole sorry Hayden in the chat
says another trade deadline another
years of wer Lakers fans wanting to sell
everyone you made the Conference finals
last year Lakers fans you make it sound
like you had a terrible campaign with
Darin ham you did the same exact thing
last year you stumbled in the middle
beginning to middle of the regular
season like you're doing this one and
then you turn up when it matters the
most this is every Lebron team ever
every game is not just hit the Devcon
one big red button people back to number
three the Mavs continue to dig and I
didn't say whole because there's still
time left to be played but the Mavs are
on this plan very similarly to what I
was alluding to at the beginning of the
show with what the New York Knicks did
for 20 years is when something doesn't
work you just mortgage the future in
hope that all of these mortgage loans
the bubble doesn't pop okay anyone
familiar with the movie The Big Short in
the way that those those trenches or
what do they call them those those loan
trenches the the Mavs have been taking
out loans on different players here
since Kristoff's porzingis trade with
the Knicks they have been trading out
draft picks they have been trading out
young guys and today they bring in they
got better today that's the thing that's
why I don't want to say they're digging
themselves in a whole but they are
taking riskier and riskier Bets and
every time you go to that casino
ATM you get your money out but they
charge you to use the ATM and you also
get hit by your bank with a fee and at
some point the daily limit hits you with
no more money is allowed you can't take
any any more money out and the Mavs are
very quickly getting to there however
they did get better today they bring in
Daniel gaffard in PJ Washington they
send out Grant Williams Seth Curry rwn
Holmes as well as some draft picks now
on the surface you're like oh well you
know it's surrounding Derrick Lively
with with Gafford and stretching the
floor with PJ Washington this is only
going to help Luca I agree with you but
just back to the conversation that we
had about the Atlanta Hawks and how
you're not going to trade someone if you
don't get the market value back for what
you just spent about a year ago Dallas
Mavericks send away Grant Williams who
they used a pick swap on just this past
summer to to acquire that pick swap I
think is five something years from now
if the Mavericks are terrible that year
that top lottery pick is going to be
going out to whatever team holds the
trade swap that that upcoming draft
these little they're just getting these
little Nicks in the Armor man these
little holes in the armor with the the
Mavs future is making it a win Now
situation for Dallas almost ASAP because
you had Grant Williams here for what
four months and it cost a trade swap to
get
him it's a lot man if you're a Mavs fan
you got to go right now Blake thinks the
Mavs are going to win the
West I'll take that bet is dwy going
back to the Mavs good you know what
let's use that as a quick talking point
so as we went live we saw Spencer deny
is likely to be bought out by the
Toronto Raptors and he will head back
into uh free agency Andor the waiver
wire uh Spencer Den witty can can't go
to teams like the Denver Nuggets that
are above the apron because of the new
collective bargaining agreement rules
but the Mavs are certainly a candidate I
would imagine the Lakers are as well
depending on what their apron situation
is I'm not I I haven't looked up their
their exact uh restrictions just yet but
a homecoming for the Mavs makes a lot of
sense there in adding dep with Spencer
deny who can still play bring him off
the bench behind
and LCA donich makes a lot of sense and
it's not going to cost you a lot like
they just spent moving on to number four
is the Oklahoma City Thunder you know
what for a lackluster trade deadline
there sure was a lot that happened today
people so I'm going to get to as many of
your comments as possible and I'm going
to try and cover as much of many of
these bases as we can because there's a
lot going on and there's so much parity
in the league that they all matter
Oklahoma City ends up training for
Gordon Hayward this morning they send
out Trey man who Ball by the way nice
job by Charlotte Trey man can hoop but
OKC brings in Gordon Hayward veteran we
know he can close out games I I don't
imagine this affects what the Oklahoma
City Thunder are already doing because I
am very much team if it's not broken
don't fix it but with Gordon Hayward
you're bringing him as the second man
off the bench in a playoff series
running alongside Aaron Wiggins running
Al alongside you know what they have
they've got 10 guys to choose from
[Music]
um I Gordon hayward's been there before
so nothing about what the Thunder are
doing now and what's made them
successful is going to change and you
get that veteran playoff leadership as
well for the cost of try man that's not
going to be included in the lineup
anyway makes a lot of sense man and they
still have what 34 draft picks in the
next decade or something that they have
access to they didn't even have to give
up any of their picks to go after Gordon
Hayward who's already on a rebuilding
Charlotte team he's probably not going
to see the floors they give some of
their young guys a look like this worked
out great for both sides and then the
Hornets of course are going to be their
own topic here they get Trey man they
get Grant Williams they get a first
round pick from
Dallas and they're gonna be likely keep
miles Bridges so the Hornets end up
Fifth on this takes and predictions list
because I want this show to be about
basketball I have eyes and ears and I
understand that there are things going
on with my miles Bridges off the floor
that will affect people's opinion of him
and both the product that he produces
but because the show is simply about
basketball assets miles Bridges is an
NBA player with a contract now what's
unique about his contract is that the
way it's structured is that he believe
it or not had in a way a node trade
clause it wasn't one of those like we're
going to agree to a node trade clause
it's the way that he signed his deal
allowed him to choose what team he could
be traded to
and this the Phoenix Suns who had been
rumored for weeks to be in the market
for Miles Bridges ultimately don't end
up getting him and I think that is
because one miles Bri it's not that
Miles Bridges doesn't want to go play
for a better team that has a chance at a
championship but miles Bridges is likely
looking out for Miles Bridges and that
if he were to accept to trade to Phoenix
they would not have his bird rights
which means they likely can't resign him
next year and when miles Bridges the all
that occurred in that offseason off the
court affected his money in a drastic
way he's likely looking out for his own
Financial well-being and for the
Charlotte Hornets franchise which
brought him back he probably sees a
future with them and a future contract
so he either declined to trade and or
just simply did not get moved to teams
that would not be able to retain his
bird rights and if they're not going to
retain his bird rights they're also not
going going to be able to send a lot
that way anyway because it's just going
to be a rental he's on a one-year deal
so miles bridg is is is falling right
now he is going crazy on the court and
as a result he's going to stay in
Charlotte and likely be with that team
for the foreseeable future number six I
don't know if we have the ability to add
more takes and predictions to this uh to
this list here maybe we wipe them clean
and type in new ones if we can but Pat
Bev and Dame is coming in at number six
uh I just want to grab a couple of chats
before I move on OKC got way better says
Armani Trey man is a bucket Charlotte
got a steal Trey man can hoop when OKC
was losing by 50 points last year in
Memphis and they were getting ready for
this Championship run Trey man going off
every single night that dude can do
anything that you need him to straight
Hooper number six Pat Bev Damen Lillard
okay first of all the Milwaukee Bucks do
not make this trade today to acquire Pat
Bev one of Damen Lillard's biggest
villains and vice versa unless Damen
Lillard said it's cool all right I want
to sit here and and create WWE as much
as you guys do like and the Box the the
Bucks are already toxic all right but
they are also a championship ready team
so they are not making decisions with
this level of risk
reward unless they're players are cool
with it and you better believe with how
much they gave up for Dame that they are
Consulting him before making this move
today we get the quote from Chris Haynes
here at Bach report who said first I
want to say I'm sad to see campaign go
we developed a friendship all that but
as for Pat he brings an edge and a
defensive tenacity on the perimeter that
we need the way that this quote reads on
the screen right now looks very prish
and we know the history between the two
it dates back to the bubble where Pat
Bev is doing the the watch and falling
overlap laughing and then Damen Lillard
roasted him in the postgame press
conference saying I sent him home as
well as going on to the Instagram
comments and saying you boys are Chumps
then Pat Bev is with the Lakers and they
get into it when Dame's at the free
throw line in Portland and then he hits
the broken watch as the Lakers are
winning and puts it in his pocket you
got Pat Bev on on a podcast today saying
that oh man I got to get the
relationship right with Dame that
suggests to me that they haven't spoken
yet so there is there we go I'mma beat
your ass right there's me zooming in on
on his the words there from Damen
Lillard saying I'mma beat your ass well
that wasn't all too long ago so Pat Bev
has had to confront a lot of his former
beefs if you will playing for whether
it's the Sixers the Lakers with Russell
Westbrook you name it um they've gotten
over it and they will ultimately get
over this one but this team does not
have the best Vibes they are
questionable at best and you hope that
Pat Bev of of course is going to be the
first to say let's put this all aside
and go win a championship together and
what we see from Chris haynes's quote
here is Damen Lillard is willing to do
that as well on the surface in the words
but in the locker room the stuff that we
can't see only time will tell on that
one and what went on with the Adrien
Griffin there you got Doc Rivers who's
one and four likely to go one and five
tonight with a game against
Minnesota keeping an eye on that one
folks keeping an eye on that one as I
don't know if Dame's going to be in a
rush to make up as quickly as Russell
Westbrook did in the past just because
it happened once doesn't mean it's going
to happen again number seven I've got
the Pacers in the 76ers we've still got
some time left here in the bleacher
report app I'm reading the comments I've
got producers helping me out as well if
you have any questions comments concerns
please drop them in there and we will
get to the the highlighted ones before
this stream ends Pacers and the 76ers
make a trade today you get buddy heeld
on the move from Marcus Morris and
corkos who been requesting a trade by
the way for the last what five years he
finally got his way he finally got out
of there now I don't know what type of
PT he plans on getting in in
Indianapolis because ultimately the
Pacers were able to replace buddy heeld
with Doug
mcder uh and I don't want to say that's
a seamless transition because buddy
heeld is shooting quite literally the
best three-point percentage of any
player in recent time from three-point
land the Sixers get get a a floor
stretcher for when embiid comes back
which they need everyone needs that uh
the Pacers have always been rumored to
be moving buddy healed and they bring in
a veteran in Marcus Morris that's going
to be alongside Pascal seaka in Miles
Turner and all of a sudden they've got
some big bodies and some killers on that
team man Benedict Maan can hope we know
about halberton this team is gearing up
for for a playoff run for sure and they
got a little bit bit more physical today
at number eight we've got the Chicago
Bulls who like the Warriors and Lakers
are fall into the category of doing
nothing if if you're a bulls fan it has
been 30 months 30 I didn't miss speak 30
months since they've made a trade for an
actual player they've made trade for
picks but we're just going to finish in
ninth place every year is just the goal
here Zack LaVine is probably out for the
remainder of the season with a with a
foot injury
was DeMar de rozan ever going to be on
the
move this
is I want to say in a way Double
Jeopardy is what's happening to the
Chicago Bulls because when you go all in
for vich the way that they did trading
wend Carter Jr and all those draft picks
you have to find a way to make it work
and or resign that player to give them
enough time to be worth the trade that
you made and the Bulls have put together
a team like if if you're playing 2K if
you're just looking at box scores like
they've got some big names out there man
and Alex Caruso of course every team in
the league would line up around the
block to acquire this guy yet they don't
make any moves and they just continue to
hover around eighth or Ninth Place at
the 500 Mark they have they have
liabilities they have a low ceiling and
they've also on the positive side they
have young pieces like Kobe white that
have developed and our in into this like
might end up being the guy on this team
one day type of type of Arc
here but you sit on Andre Drummond when
you know there's a market out there the
Lakers could use Andre Drummond back
Oklahoma City could have used Andre
Drummond back what is the purpose of
Andre Drummond still being on the
Chicago Bulls past the trade deadline
because he's ultimately going to go for
nothing when you could have brought in a
pick it doesn't mean you have to use the
pick pick right now even if you want to
stay in Pat but you can have that pick
for future use when the Chicago Bulls
it's not a they're not ever going to
rebuild there because that's not what
their owner does he's even said it
publicly they don't do rebuilds don't
say the word rebuild around here but man
they need a Reload or a restructure
because this team is never winning a
championship and unless there's a
miracle they're not winning a first
round playoff series and then you don't
go to the lottery and then you just kind
of repeat this over and over again and I
understand keeping D rozan there because
the guy is good damn good Caruso Kobe
white Caruso is important Kobe White's
potential is the seal there's no ceiling
right now I get
it but between Pat Williams between
Andre Drummond they're still in uniform
and then we're going to go to the
playoffs and Get Smoked by the Boston
Celtics if we come out of the playing
tournament what are we doing here
no worse place to be in the NBA than
mediocrity and the Bulls have perfected
that Mexican leopard says I'd love a car
chase live after this wob and talk to
bleacher report about that if they want
to be streaming car chases in here uh
after NBA tread deadline Uzi air says
Damon Pat Bev former Ops now friends
can't make it
up I'm assume Ops means enemies I'm too
old for whatever that means so um yeah
former enemies now friends on the same
team how many times has Pat Bev had to
had to do that
recently the shooter says bro you're hot
AF NL I don't know what that means but
I'll take that as a compliment thank you
uh
hopefully what else I'm G to scroll some
more comments
here see if there's anything that I've
missed before we keep moving on I
promised I'd go in here in case in case
there was extra forgive me for a second
when I'm looking on this side of the
screen it's because I'm reading your
comments comments as quickly as I can we
talked about the Knicks at the top of
the show I do think the Knicks move is
the highlight of the day
yes okay uh Magic's stagnant
thoughts yeah listen the magic are in a
position as a franchise that they are
never going to get a A-list or an
unrestricted free agency which means
they need to trade and or draft them and
they have such a young core that is
locked up long term that you're not
trading fron Vagner Bon Caro Suggs any
of these dudes for practically anyone
that's not named Steph Curry or jannis
sinten Goomba why would you let them
develop on their own do your own version
of Oklahoma City it's very
possible and it's expedited how good Bon
Caro's been this year they're above 500
right at
it let's keep going we still got some
time time left here and I got more
topics uh number nine is going to be the
trade that happened oh so the Suns
sneaky day for the Suns they are limited
in what they can do because of how
they've assembled their their roster and
once again how the first and second
aprons in the luxury tax of the NBA is
currently
structured they pull off a trade today
in which they get race O'Neal Who was on
that list earlier this week of guys that
I thought was most likely to be traded
and towards the top of that list they
get Royce O'Neal from the Brooklyn Nets
as well as Rody from Memphis the Nets
get kada Bates G deop Jordan Goodwin
three second rounders and The Grizzlies
get UDA Wabi and chimi metu Grizzlies
made out well too because UDA as
Grizzlies fans know is awesome the Suns
get two uh floor stretchers there of
which chimzi metu was not fulfilling uh
that role and we know after watching
what the Nuggets did to the Suns last uh
playoffs in leaving Josh aogi wide open
they were going to have to solve that
we're playing offense four on five
regardless if we have a big three or not
and by adding Royce O'Neal to the roster
today that is no longer a liability you
can no longer play four on five defense
against the Phoenix Suns with Royce
O'Neal or Rody on the floor those two
guys can hoop and they've got playoff
experience
too who are buyout candidates for second
apron teams ISO Joe asks well the second
apron teams are limited in just about
everything that they can do so if you're
talking about putting getting guys on a
veteran's minimum there is a rule which
is why Denver can't sign Spencer deny
that if they were making a certain
amount before you are not allowed to go
out there and sign them as a waiver free
agent on a minimum deal you're
restricted in what you can do so uh I
don't have the list of players that are
going to enter the buyout Market that's
second apron teams can do can go out and
get you're talking about some two-way
guys and why pton Watson is getting a
ton of run because they're GNA need him
the same way that they needed Christian
Brown last year they're gonna have to
find that Bruce Brown role and it's not
going to come from the buyout
Market speaking of the buyout Market
great way for me to get to the bottom of
this list with bones Highland and PJ
Tucker two names who have disappeared
into the abyss bones Highland is B on
the Clippers after making his run with
the nuggets and having some some Big
Time games and performances and and
Twitter highlights bones Highland still
trapped at the end of that bench with PJ
Tucker neither of which get
traded and that Clippers team is so good
and so deep that they're not going to be
seeing the light of day anytime soon
unless there's an injury so that b no
one could work out a trade for bones
Highland is kind of crazy to me because
all it would cost I would think is is a
guaranteed couple second round pick
picks but the Clippers are standing path
there uh a team that I had no clue which
way they were going to move was the Utah
Jazz were they gonna be buyers or
Sellers and in a way they were both so
they trade Kelly oen today and aaji as
well but they don't trade Jordan
Clarkson they hold on to majority of
their guys are sitting right at 500 in
the playin tournament and I kind of want
to believe that they think that we are a
playoff team and as long as if they keep
Jordan Clarkson Because they could have
gotten a lot for him Jordan Clarkson
loves Utah and Utah loves Jordan
Clarkson Jordan Clarkson moved his
family to Utah has a big reason for him
staying in uniform there is he wants to
be a part of that team long-term moving
forward and the Jazz are willing
to accept
that best potential buyout player right
now into who ask Mexican leopard uh Kyle
so the trade with Pat Bev today today
all but opens up a spot for Kyle Larry a
Philly guy a Villanova guy to step right
in and and join the 76ers from the
buyout market so I I don't want to say
that's obvious because nothing
everything can change but that would not
surprise me in the least that Kyle Larry
is going to be a 76er here in the near
future as well as someone like Spencer
Denwood he's probably going to end up
either in Dallas and or Los Angeles
depending on those uh apron restrictions
and then finally the Pistons man my God
I it I don't want to say they bottomed
out and they're they're starting over
because they've kind of been starting
over for the last five years but they
just gave up on Killian hay today he's
just
gone and I if I see no don't drop your
knee house in the chat please it's more
bonj than anything for
him a preferred change of scenery
from his Camp I think everyone on the
Pistons is going to want to change of
scenery but good news is you're getting
Quinton Grimes coming in alongside Jaden
Ivy Kate Cunningham jayen durren they
got young guys to build around there and
you got to build somewhere but it was
not working with the guys that they got
Kevin Knox on his way out
too
okay that is all of my takes if you will
winners losers let's do that right now
biggest winners of the day are the New
York Knicks the Charlotte Hornets the
Oklahoma City
Thunder as well
as the Suns you know what I'll give the
Suns a biggest biggest winners of the
day biggest losers Pistons as
always um bulls for sure TBD on the
Bucks see how this works out I guess I
can always just
tell Pat Bev to stay home uh but
Bulls
Pistons uh and I I don't want to say the
Warriors or Lakers were losers because
if they made a move an aggressive move
to go all in and it didn't work out then
they wouldn't even have the summer to
reevaluate neither of them made a panic
move none of them made any moves that is
going to get them any closer to a
championship but there's so much parody
in the west that injuries and uh things
can happen in series that the the lers
just happen to have themselves the most
ideal path going to a championship this
year and end up back in the Conference
Finals with D'Angelo Russell at point
guard so anything else in the chat
before we
go got awfully quiet I know I'm doing
okay on this show when the chat quiets
down a little bit because it means
you're
listening and for those of you that were
on the show earlier this week remember
when I misspoke and I said Monte Morris
was still on the Washington Wizards and
he's not he was on the Detroit Pistons
he's not on the Detroit Pistons anymore
got
traded so there you go to everyone in
the chat from the last
show uh last we'll take let's see how
much time we got left we'll go a couple
more minutes here TJ m78 ask do you
consider the Lakers losers for not
making moves or do they have no choice
they don't have anything to move besides
D'Angelo Russell and Max Christie so
that's your only deal the only feasible
way to make any sort of trade was by
putting those two together don't have
any draft picks that anyone cares about
you have you're not trading ruy Aura you
need him no one cares about Jackson
Hayes it is DLo and Max Christie maybe
Austin Reeves of which they're not
trading either because they got burned
by Caruso they're not making that
mistake again it's those two and if you
can't find the right deal for that then
you stand Pat because D'Angelo Russell's
been awesome
awesome and you hope that he can stay
awesome through the playoff run but you
got LeBron out here tweeting hourglass
emoji wearing wearing Nick shoes and
doing doing his thing that he always
does trying to pressure front offices
and be cryptic and sub twe and I
understand why people probably think
that the Lakers were losers today
because they did nothing to satisfy that
Lust For whatever it is that he wants
that none of us can speak
to thank you to Shooter who says you're
my favorite BR
streamer well hopefully br brings us
back we've done some therapy sessions in
the past after playoff games if there's
something to discuss I'm sure uh we'll
get back together for another
Edition but for now I think guys that's
going to do
it do I see the Knicks going to get
Killian as
security
uh I Tom
Tibido the last thing he wants is a
young rookie scale player
that is not proven to be a Tibido guy
the only reason why Duce McBride got
that contract is because he's the most
Tibido point guard ever and he was cheap
timido traditionally goes to his trusted
veterans especially on a team that is
now going to be contending for a
championship so Quinton Grimes was the
last piece to
go so my answer is no I don't think they
will uh but crazier things have happened
I
guess
all right on that note we have reached
our time here about 10 minutes over
because I love you
guys uh trade deadline 2024 is coming
gone thank you all that uh follow along
as well as uh streamed here in the
bleacher report app I hope that we get
to do it again soon sometime until then
I'll be sitting right here watching the
games and I hope to see you on the
timeline